you are in no position to be taking
liberties I will not warn you again I
depend on a lot of cues because I cannot
hear a single thing and not the tiniest
little sound and no beats no music
nothing
we have several different kinds of cues
that we use in the show the main one and
the one that I prefer our actor driven
cues and those are derived from normal
looking pedestrian movements that a
person would make and that don't draw
your eye like folding her arms leaning
forward simply looking over at an actor
simple body shift it's I think the the
most complicated piece and the part that
the audience doesn't notice at all I've
been doing this like right before I sing
the lyrics so there's kind of this like
1 second delay so I'll lift my head they
know one second after that to start
their signs a tiny little thing like
nodding your head at the right time
could could really screw up a whole
number
I have someone who's sitting with his
hand on the bed and when his right hand
opens and I see that then I crumple the
paper now when another person stands up
that is my cue to start signing and I
guess it sort of goes on like that and
each time Daniel takes a letter that's a
cue that he's about to get ready and and
then we have an actor take the letter
from him at the beginning of every one
of his musical phrases
it creates a lot of really interesting
moments where you know on one side of
the stage you'll see me singing the song
with Daniel while he's signing the thing
and we just create this kind of really
unique experience that I've personally
never seen on a stage before
music is not an art form that's
typically available to the deaf
community
so in this production we're not just
bringing sign language to hearing people
we're bringing musicals into the deaf
community as well so to do that we have
to make music accessible to a deaf
audience so one thing that we work
really hard to do is bring the emotion
that's in the fabric of the musical and
the story into the language that we use
to perform the music in the translation
process you've got to match the rhythm
the composer wrote a certain rhythm into
these lines say four beats to align how
are we going to find a sign translation
that matches that rhythm smoothly is it
a strong piece of music or is it soft
that's an important part of the
translation as a deaf person I've never
heard music before so I depend on the
hearing members of our team once we
understand from them how the music goes
we try to find an equivalent I've
learned a lot through the process it's
an incredible challenge probably the
most challenging role I've ever had but
it's been fantastic if another musical
was offered to me I mean I'd take it
immediately I love music it's really
been wonderful